what did you guys think when you read
that or maybe you heard from Kirk
directly that he bought Peter Green from
Fleetwood Mac's guitar and how many what
did you pay a couple of million bucks
for it right am I correct did you no no
that's that's the rumor I would never
pay a couple million dollars for just
about anything but you bought that
guitar why so the owner came to me Manny
he was in financial streets
and I said to him I don't I'm not gonna
buy a two million dollar guitar and he
said it's not two million dollars that's
you know that's poppycock you know
British guy and so he he brought it to
my hotel
you know I I plugged it in and literally
within 30 seconds Howard I said you're
not getting this guitar back because
it's amazing sounding guitar hey Justin
while you bring the bring Greenie please
Greenie is the guitar you bought and you
use it on stage yes yes and so the The
Legend and there is a legend to it is
that Peter Green bought it in 1965 and
Peter Green was a guy who formed
Fleetwood Mac and on that guitar he
wrote Black Magic Woman oh well
Albatross green manalishi amongst a
bunch of other songs
and then in 1971 he sold it to Gary
Moore for 150 and then Gary Moore had it
for like the next 30 Years and played it
on a bunch of thin Nissi albums
including my favorite thing is the album
black rose and so greedy has a really
unique sound
wow James what do you think of this
greeny have you heard it before
I played it before he did I don't know
if you know this yeah I know I knew yeah
the guy brought it backstage to show it
to me and uh I rejected it
and I played it before James yeah
but that's why it got so expensive Lars
played it yeah thanks Lars is this
greeny that I'm looking at right now
this is greeny yeah yeah and it's known
for two sounds the the the the neck
pickup sound let's hear it super syrupy
[Music]
thank you
it has really great sustain and then
it's it's known for the middle position
and its sound is out of phase right
foreign
when it's out of phase it sounds like a
Fender Strat and that's Paul's are not
supposed to sound like fenders but this
guitar does in the middle position and
that was so unique to me I said to the
guy you're not getting this guitar back
I'll give you what you want I'm I'm but
I'm keeping this thing I I picked up on
the energy and the Mojo of this guitar
immediately and it's I'm it's
Inseparable now where I sleep it's it's
literally 10 feet from me no matter
where I am I keep it and bring it
everywhere and play it on stage too did
Hendrix play that guitar and George
Harrison as well yes Hendrix George
Harrison Jeff Beck Rory Gallagher I mean
the list goes on larzores Lars all right
that's right wow maybe
yeah
foreign